[Music]
who voices Daniel
Radcliffe in bodak Horseman me it would
have been actually an amazing
considering what the the episode the
joke that that episode ends with if is
if they had had Elijah would voice me in
that but they did not who does Elijah
Wood look like apparently a lot like
Daniel Radcliffe who does Daniel
Radcliff look like oh a perfect zague
the idea of me and Elijah Wood is the
same we don't actually look that alike
but if you imagine all our component
parts we're just sort of short pale
blue-eyed big eyed brown haired people
who does Elijah Wood look like see above
I suppose I would love to be in a movie
with Elijah Wood at this point it feels
like it would have to be something that
is consciously using the way the world
sees us as linked and and you know uh
similar looking I'm very open to pitches